now even as the united states was
bringing in a new administration on
tuesday
china was slapping sanctions against the
old one
28 top officials of donald trump's
administration
including former secretary of state mike
pompeo was sanctioned by china for court
lying and cheating the measures have
been described as unproductive and
cynical
by biden administration officials the
new sanctions
underline the fraught relationship
between both countries
and if we needed any indication of how
it will develop over the next four years
president biden's nominee for secretary
of state anthony blinken
had this to say during his senate
confirmation hearing
i also believe that president trump was
right
in taking a tougher approach to china
i disagree very much with the way that
he went about it in a number of areas
but
the basic principle was the right one
and i think that's actually helpful
and there were other indications as well
from lincoln about the future u.s stance
on key issues with china
secretary pompeo designated the chinese
communist party as having
engaged in genocide regarding the uyghur
muslim population do you agree with that
that would be my judgment as well
you do agree yes there's been a strong
and long
bipartisan commitment to taiwan
the taiwan relations act also the
communiques
with china and part of that commitment
is making sure
that um taiwan have the ability
um to defend itself uh against
aggression
uh and that is a commitment that will uh
absolutely endure
uh in a uh an abiding industry for more
i'm joined now by professor steve tzang
he's director of the china institute
at the school of oriental and african
studies in london professor tsang
welcome
do you think we are looking at some sort
of a reset in ties between the us and
china
well the chinese government would like a
reset in u.s china relations
i think the washington side will see
a largely continuation of the
relationship
but a different style of managing it
when you said that the chinese
government is also looking for a reset
what do you mean by that
well the chinese government really has
been very unhappy with the
way how the trump administration has
been dealing with
china particularly in the last
few weeks of the trump administration
over initiatives on relaxing control
over
meetings between u.s officials and the
american officials as well as the
classification
of what happens in xinjiang as a kind of
genocide when it comes to the ties
between the united states
and china do you think that the
direction the future course of ties
between these two nations
will influence how the u.s approaches
its ties
with other countries in the region
i think it will
where i think we have is a new
administration in washington
which recognized that administrations
prior to the trump administration
had been less than entirely realistic in
dealing with china
and they didn't want to make the same
mistakes that previous administrations
have
made they also realized the trump
administration didn't
approach china very effectively
but they saw some of the basic strategic
thinking of the trump administration as
being
uh appropriate so they want to
keep to that and how the chinese will
respond to it
will affect how the americans feel that
they need to
react to china and engage with american
allies
in asia which are the same countries
that china wants to engage with
when you talk about this new sense of
realism
what shape might that realism take from
the biden administration
i think we have seen the uh the biola
administration
or indeed joe biden himself in his
inaugural
speech saying that valued
matters truth matters
and the chinese government has a
relationship with the truth
that is more similar to the way how the
trump administration had with truth
and that would pose a significant
problem for the
uh biden administration so it will take
a robust stance towards china
but it will also tries to engage with
china
to find ways to make things work
rather than take a confrontational
approach for the sake of it
i don't think there's any doubt or
argument that china plays a very very
important role and a very big one
in asia but help us understand professor
sang how
exactly china views its role in asia
well china really sees that is
long-term rifled place in asia
is to be the leader of asia
china would like itself to be perceived
in asia
as the benevolent big brother
and the other asian countries simply
running around
to support china and build up a
community under the leadership of china
now that may not be the way how a lot of
the countries in southeast asia
or indeed japan may see it but that's
how the chinese government would like it
to be
seeing as we are likely to see more
confrontation between the u.s and china
all be it in a form different to that
scene under the trump administration
are there any areas of cooperation
between the two countries
well there are areas where the two
countries can easily
cooperate for example uh on the issue of
climate change the byte administration
is reversing completely its approach on
this compared to the trump
administration
and therefore we should be quite
happy is to cooperate with the chinese
to move things forward that's not a
zero-sum game between the two countries
will the chinese government cooperate
with the biden administration
on climate change that remains to be
seen
will they be able to work out some kind
of a better economic relationship
rather than focus on the tariff war
against that remains to be seen
uh biden is not going to just dismantle
all the tariff regimes
in place he wants gustam's negotiate
it depends on how the chinese respond
interesting times ahead for us
professor steve tsang from sos in london
thank you so much sir for joining us
turning now to southeast asia where the
u.s has had a long-time military and
diplomatic presence
besides troops in many countries here
the united states has
formal defense arrangements with south
korea japan and the philippines
the military support is in a region with
significant security concerns
including china's claim over most of the
south china sea
the unilateral claims have often led to
a war of words
and small-scale confrontations on the
seas between chinese ships and those
from other countries
with competing claims in the region this
is in addition to long-running tensions
on the korean peninsula
which jointly impact relations between
the u.s
china japan and south korea
so let's break this down further joining
me now is sitting in pongs with iraq
he's director of the
institute of security and international
studies at chulalongkorn university in
bangkok welcome mr pongx with iraq i
realize it's very hard to generalize
about southeast asia and east asia
but do countries in the region have a
somewhat underlying common expectation
from the new u.s administration
yes i think broadly speaking the
southeast asian countries would like to
see more
reliability and dependability from u.s
administrations
the trump government the trump
administration has been a bit
erratic you know we had a trade war with
china
technology conflict and so on so i think
there's a lot of
anticipation about new administration
that maybe
can provide more more balance more peace
and stability in the regions
and maybe a bit of a new chapter because
i think it's been very tumultuous uh
during the term period
however uh the u.s china trade
technology conflict
has been viewed favorably in southeast
asia so i think what southeast asia
would like to see is that
it's some kind of a balance you know
between maybe the obama time and the
trump administration
under obama i think the u.s left a lot
to be desired in the region to
raise a lot of expectations but
unfulfilled with the pivot and rebalance
and china kind of took over the south
china sea during that time
trump went the other way very
belligerent and a bit erratic and
unpredictable
so i think maybe violent we hope will be
something in between speaking of balance
uh you have china that looms large in
southeast asia as you also
pointed out do countries in the region
have this unique challenge to balance
the relationship with the us
with ties with china even though many
have territorial disputes and
disagreements with china
yeah countries in the region do not want
to be dominated
by by china generally speaking or by any
major power i think that the region
would like to see
some tension between us and china
because that allows
leverage uh you know for the the asian
smaller states at the same time they
don't want to see an outright war on
conflict uh
you know even the trade war that we've
seen has been very
uh a bit unstable unstable and so on so
we would like to see something in
between
um i think for china uh it's a
residential
super power i think the the the smaller
states would like to see some kind of
balance
between the two u.s and china speaking
of china again china plays an important
role in at least
two issues that are long running in the
region one is the south china sea
dispute
and also it has a role to play uh when
it comes to tensions
on the korean peninsula and what it can
do to potentially calm them
but are we likely to see any changes in
the u.s
approach to these areas of concern
it remains to be seen but the the people
around
president biden seem to come from the
obama period
so i think the biden administration will
be tested very early on
by north korea we already see some
challenges there and also i think the
chinese also will test the biden
administration the way it did with the
obama administration
and then for for southeast asia south
china sea is a major hot spot
but also in mainland southeast asia the
medical regions
around the mekong river where china has
built these upstream dams
unilaterally is also a major issue so i
think
across the region from northeast asia to
southeast asia a number of hot spots a
lot of
contentious issues by the administration
that will be
watched very carefully what kind of
people they put in charge of the region
i think that they will be more attentive
to the region we already
see some some hopeful optimistic words
from the uh people like kurt campbell
and so on so the early signs are good
from the
demonstrations and maybe they can be
something like you know not obama 2.0
but maybe this is a second
chance for the wider administration to
do what the obama administration tried
to do but did not succeed
an interesting space to watch but thank
you so much for joining us today 39
points with iraq